- Sur le coup, moi,
je n'ai pas voulu parler
d'un attentat politique.
- En entrevue aux "Coulisses
du pouvoir", l'ancienne première
ministre Pauline Marois avoue
avoir regretté ce choix.
Elle ne voulait pas exacerber
ion, déjà tendue,
entre le Parti québécois et
la communauté anglo-québécoise.
(applaudissements)
Pourtant, tous les critères
d'un attentat politique
étaient rassemblés.
- Pauline! Pauline! Oui!
Ce soir-là, les péquistes
acclament leur cheffe,
devenue la première femme
à diriger la province.
(applaudissements)
D'un coup, ses gardes du corps
se précipitent sur elle.
Elle est évacuée
en catastrophe.
- Est-ce que, Martine,
vous êtes sur place?
- Aucune idée, Patrice,
de ce qui vient de se passer.- e
éclate à l'arrière
du Metropolis.
- Les anglais sont réveillés.
Payback!
d Henry Bain,
lourdement armé, est ensuite
arrêté par la police.
Il aura tué un technicien
de scène et blessé un deuxième.
Mais Bain visait
la nouvelle premi
ministre et ses partisans.
- Pauline Marois, quant à elle,
est retournée sur scène
pour terminer son discours
de victoire.
- C'est un exemple d'une femme
cheffe d'État, voilà!
(applaudissements)
te seule journée
du 4 septembre 2012, la Sûreté
du Québec avait enregistré
six menaces sérieuses
à son endroit. Dix ans plus
tard, Pauline Marois se désoleds
antidémocratique, qu'elle
attribue à l'élection
de Donald Trump.
PAULINE MAROIS, ancienne
première ministre du Québec
- Ce niveau de violence,
d'agression verbalion verbalione
et de risque a augmenté.
- Une tension exacerbée
durant les campagnesélectoralest
de la radicalisation.
LOUIS AUDET GOSSELIN, directeur
scientifique et stratégique
- La niveau des menaces
augmente, et la précision
des menaces augmente aussi.
Il y a une personnalisation
des menat assezt assezt assezt z
inquiétante.
- La Sûreté du Québec a mis
en place une ligne téléphonique
uniquement pour les candidats,
mais est-ce efficace?
FRANÇOIS DORÉ, ex-membre
ûreté du Québec
- La personne qui a des menaces
chez elle devant sa maison
par d'autres personnes
ne fera pas la ligne...
ne composera pas cette ligne,
mais va appeler directementle 9,
elle est utile, mais elle a
quand même ses limites aussi.
- En attendant, la sécurité
se resserre autour des chefs
de partis. Mais le débat devra
dépasser l'ajout de policier
estiment des experts.
Il en va de la défense
de la démocratie.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Montréal.